professor vino
voloneck of concordia university asks
the derivational theory of complexity
was created and rejected when cognitive
neuroscience
was at a relatively early underdeveloped
stage
since generative grammars are realist
theories
that are supposed to characterize the
actual functioning of the brain
do you think that the derivational
theory of complexity
was discarded prematurely and that
recent advancements in neuroscience
and brain imaging have the potential to
vindicate it
well the derivational theory of
complexity was
an interesting idea proposed by
george miller friend and colleague
or fine outstanding psychologist back
probably late 50s early 60s so the idea
was that
you could measure the complexity of
processing of an expression by looking
at the number of operations that
entered into generating it
they had some initial successes with
experiments
then they started not working
there was also another problem it was
based on
conceptions of language that were
fairly prevalent at the time but these
keep changing as we
learn more as in the example we just
discussed
about x-bar theory and that means that
the ranking of expressions in terms of
derivational complexity
changes as the theories change well for
an experimentalist that's
a problem means you have to redo the
experiments every time some new idea
shows
up these problems lead to
pretty much abandonment of the idea
maybe with more refined theories it
might be possible to reconstitute it
the more general question that's raised
by the questioner is the relation
between
the theories postulated within the study
of
generative grammar and the actual
neural realization of them there is a
big gap
but there's the same gap for everything
else
the brain sciences are not
out of state where you can
relate any moderately complex trait to
what's going on in the brain
you can do it very loosely you know i
can say this area of the brain is
firing when you're doing so and so
but what's going on in that area of the
brand we know
very little about uh here's where
penrose has actually
had some ideas about uh quantum
theoretic
approaches to the internal
structure of neurons which has a rich
internal
structure possibly a basis for
a great deal of computation but not very
much is understood about that
if that's correct the whole structure
of much of the
brain side of the neuroscience is
on the wrong track when it's looking at
neural nets there's
other reasons to think that so basically
we don't really know where to look
now randy galissell has done very
important work on this
is i think very convincing work showing
that
neural nets just do not have the
possible possibility of
developing the core element
in any computational system
just doesn't have that capacity so
using the model of which he sometimes
does of the
drunk looking under the lamppost for his
watch which he lost somewhere else but
when asked why are you looking here he
says that's because that's where the
light is
but the light is where you have neural
nets but it's probably not where things
are happening
so this is not a criticism of the brain
sciences it's very hard
in particular if you take a look at say
the study of language
the study of the neural basis of
language
is extraordinarily hard because you
cannot do
experiments you can imagine all kinds of
experiments
invasive experiments that would give
rich information about the nature of
language and its use but you can't do
the experiments
for ethical reasons we just don't allow
invasive experiments with humans like
say
raising a child under controlled
conditions
or sticking electrodes into the brain or
something like that now we do allow it
rightly or wrongly at least we used to
may not anymore
with other animals okay so in fact we've
learned a great deal about
the neuroscience of human vision
by invasive experiments with
cats let's say for example the famous
hubil weasel nobel prize winning
experiments which
gave a tremendous amount of information
about
peripheral processing of visual stimuli
and cats since humans have about the
same visual system as cats
it's apparently true of humans too so we
know
a lot about that but in the case of
language
there's no other organism there's no
there are no analogous systems in other
organisms
it's essentially unique so even if we
allowed
invasive experimentation say with
chimpanzees or
uh crows or whatever other
birds show high level of animals show
high levels of
some kind of intellectual activity it's
no use
because they don't have these systems
so the in multiple ways study of the
neural basis for language extremely
difficult
there are results but they're limited
there's another problem all of the
studies that are carried out
are studies of the use of language
but there's a fundamental distinction
which actually goes back to aristotle
between possession of knowledge and use
of knowledge
those are two distinct things modern
terms it's called
competence and performance now what we
observe
is the use of knowledge but there's
something else
the storage of knowledge what's the
nature of the system that's stored that
you
access and using it and we don't know
how to experiment with that
you just don't know where to look uh
actions at least you know where to look
person is saying something you can see
what area of the brain
fires up you know but or if there's
a language disorder you can see if the
the actions of using the language are
related to some area of the brain that
might be affected
there's a lot of work on that but it's
all
study of production or sometimes
perception of language
that's use of the system not the nature
of the system which remains
fixed no matter how you use it
we have the same store of knowledge
whether we're using it or not